[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
paul ryan
[Music]
and chuck todd is an [ __ ] oh boy
welcome to america
this morning here monday july 11th
breaking news
tomorrow's hearings time has changed
uh originally it was supposed to be a
morning hearing but now
it is in the afternoon make sure
to update your schedules tomorrow
the gavel will go down at 1 00 pm
eastern time is when the select
committee will gabble in we will do an
hour before
with a panel for coverage for you for
january 6 select committee
hearing day eight i believe is what
we're on
day seven no day seven day seven day i i
don't know
regardless go over to the midas touch
youtube channel make sure to follow the
link and record the new time the new
time will be noon eastern is when we
will start our coverage we will have a
panel an hour before
to give all the various legal and
political opinions and analysis of what
the
committee will bring
tomorrow is supposed to be the proud
boys oath keepers day apparently
jason von t van tattenhoven is going to
be testifying before the january 6
select committee um very important
testimony when it comes to stuart rhodes
and the oath keepers as far as what
their aim was as an organization
and how
they were seditious
i think i think that is what
tattenhoeven is as a character witness
um for stuart rhodes we all know that
stuart rhodes
testified
and was deposed by the january 6 select
committee
under oath
uh he's wanting to come in and do it
publicly in front of live cameras i
think the
select committee is going to tell him to
go [ __ ] himself when it comes to uh live
in front of the cameras the same with
steve bannon we know steve bannon
supposed to have his
um
contempt trial very soon i believe so
that steve because steven is gonna be
charged with contempt are found guilty
of contempt very quickly he knows that
trump knows that here's here's the
problem i think here's the problem that
steve bannon and trump are having with
steve bannon being found guilty of
contempt of congress
i think all the shenanigans that they've
done including over the weekend where
donald trump waived an executive order
or executive privilege that he does not
have to allow steve bannon to pretend
like he wants to go before the select
committee now
i believe i believe that the judge
when steve bannon
is found guilty very quickly of contempt
of congress it's not going to be a long
process
the defense will try to stall and put up
a long case but it's only going to be so
long that the defense can have in an
open court in front of a jury
to make the case that he was not in
contempt of congress the only evidence
that they're really going to have is
these last few days of stupidity
of donald trump and steve banning
waiving
his executive privilege that he does not
have that's why he's charged with
contempt of congress
here
i believe it's not going to take long
for that trial to happen the jury to
make their decision that yeah he's
guilty of contempt of congress it's
pretty obvious
but here's the thing the the sentencing
hearing will be set
and steve bannon will go to federal
prison folks
it is a possibility that here in the
next few months steve bannon has to
report to federal prison think about
that for a second that's exciting to a
lot of us right now it seems as if the
judge may give him six months a year i
think a year is the maximum a hundred
thousand dollars is a maximum fine
think about this for a second think
about why this is so important to donald
trump that steve bannon does not go to
prison think about this it is super
important to keep their propaganda
machine going steve bannon has one of
the highest rated podcasts in this
country believe you me it makes no sense
to me either and
baffles me but that is their propaganda
machine imagine turning off
their propaganda machine
imagine
how detrimental to trump and his message
of the big lie that would be to continue
the soft moving coup
now we seen i'm going to show you
footage later over the weekend at this
[ __ ] uh
nazi rally in in alaska where christina
bob that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
christina bob
who was apparently now a trump attorney
not an oan correspondent or a department
of homeland security former attorney she
was in the war room with bannon
and giuliani trying to steal our
government
this [ __ ] [ __ ] was in front of a
camera over the weekend talking about
the soft moving coup how they want to
make sure that they still overturn the
2020 election
he was even trump himself was
complaining
on his fraudulent social media site
about the wisconsin supreme court
decision about ballot boxes acting as if
this is retroactive decisions these
people really are [ __ ] boneheads but
that's not the point the point is that
they are trying to stoke violence is
what they're trying to do
they're trying
to stoke violence
we're gonna watch a couple clips of
christina bob
here today on the tony michael's podcast
i'm going to show you this slot soft
moving coup that they're trying to
attempt and steve bannon
steve bannon is integral part of the
propaganda machine to make this soft
moving coup go over
donald trump is relying on steve bannon
to talk to the masses he's his garbles
to talk to the masses
to make sure that they're brainwashed
into voting for trump candidates
and why they need to vote for trump
candidates imagine turning that machine
off
imagine turning that machine off they're
terrified folks
also donald trump is terrified of what
pat sipoloni
said or more really what he didn't say
trump wanted him to go in and lie for
him and pat sipoloni wouldn't do it and
we already have the evidence we're gonna
see tomorrow we're going to see tomorrow
and thursday
that pat sipoloni did what he should
have done
months of months ago
patsy bologne is terrified of criminal
legal
liability here after
cassidy hutchinson
testified in public in open court as it
were
in front of the select committee
a court of public opinion mind you and
this is the most important thing folks
this is the most important thing
about this select committee and what is
going to happen tomorrow and thursday
is the court a public opinion
[ __ ] criminal court fight criminal court
yeah we
the doj is going to do the part of the
criminal trials here
whoever's liable eastman clark giuliani
bannon trump himself the kids whoever it
is
mark meadows who is criminally liable
for the obstruction and the overturn
trying to overturn our election
and trying to steal our government
and breaking the oath to the
constitution possibly seditious
conspiracy
possibly treason
if they were using acts of war which
maybe we'll find out tomorrow more about
that apparently there is word over the
weekend
that proud boys and oath keepers may
have been bringing explosive devices to
washington
to the capitol
sounds like terrorism to me
but the court of public opinion is
important here
and bannon is their propaganda machine
and trump is terrified of that
propaganda machine being turned off and
it will be turned off
if
steve bannon is found guilty and the
judge sentenced him to a federal prison
sentence regardless if it's three months
six months or a year
steve bannon will not be able to talk
into a microphone he won't
he will not be able to do it
and that's what terrifies them
it scares the living bejesus out of them
because they won't be able to spread
their lies they won't be able to
brainwash these people because there's
no one better at it
than steve bannon at this point
there's no better sycophant than steve
bannon i mean that's what the pardon was
for folks
that was the ultimate trade in the
pardon don't you think i mean i believe
that i think that's the way it looks
i'll pardon you if you become a loyal
subject to me after joe biden takes
office and we will spread propaganda
from
here to kingdom come
and stoke our supporters
into terrorism and violence to overthrow
the government of the united states and
we'll try again
it's what they're doing now
jesus christ that's what they were doing
in this [ __ ] nazi rally up in alaska
they're trying to convince these people
that the 2020 election isn't over
jesus christ mike lindell
but my bellow guy hey oh jesus christ
this guy is all foam no beer
i swear to god every everyone makes fun
of this guy for like is his his previous
crack habit and everything
i don't know if that even is
just a a
sliver of what is wrong with that
[ __ ] but apparently mike lindell
is going to hold some big event some
earth shattering event
in august that's going to change the
course of history just like his [ __ ]
last year the cyber
symposium that him and bannon again
there's bannon again held that was going
to change the supreme court's mind and
the supreme court was going to convene
and i don't know wave their magic wand
and make trump the king
which is not a thing in our constitution
it doesn't exist
this this thing that they're trying to
do it doesn't exist
it's not a thing that exists
now now they've really convinced
their base that is the thing that exists
and then you know
i guess it's easy to convince them of
things
but mike lindell says in august he's
gonna hold the biggest meeting ever in
the history of ever ever
and it's gonna crown donald trump king i
guess i don't know i don't know he must
have pulled new evidence out of his ass
wiped it off and
gonna try to sell it to us as a as a
mine pillow i don't know in august the
20th and 21st he's supposed to hold a
big huge event
that's going to be the biggest in our
country's history in springfield
missouri now folks i'm from missouri i
know springfield missouri very well
actually
it's not too far from branson
it's not too far from the arkansas
border in fact or the oklahoma border or
kansas for that matter now springfield
missouri is the third largest
city in missouri
which is not saying much if you consider
the word city
but it's in this the southwest part of
the state
near branson joplin arkansas oklahoma
kansas near that corner
and here's the thing
if you were going to hold an event that
was going to be earth shattering is
going to change the world
i don't know that you would really pick
springfield missouri i mean maybe if you
threw a dart and a map and that's where
it landed what i'm thinking my thought
is is that this is the largest place
that they could actually hold this thing
where they haven't stiffed the [ __ ]
the city the county and they won't allow
them the whole big events that's why
trump has big events and cattle fields
because he can't go to big places
anymore he's on the dole for them he
owes them money they won't let him hold
events anywhere because he [ __ ] has a
bill that he needs to pay because he's a
[ __ ] deadbeat that's why he's got to
go have it at a [ __ ]
a podunk [ __ ] county fairground or a
cattle [ __ ] field or a sheep field as
it were
because he [ __ ] knows all these
places money
so i think that's probably why they
picked springfield missouri
it's in the bible belt they'll surely
get a bunch of sheep
to migrate to springfield missouri
and they'll surely hurt them up
and feed them a bunch of horse [ __ ] or
sheep [ __ ] whichever you consider
really is bone-edited type stuff here
and i'm going to show you i'm going to
show you the [ __ ] word sell it that
this guy talks about i don't even know
what the [ __ ] this event is he can't
even explain it because they don't know
what it is folks they don't know what it
is because this is the soft moving coup
that's what this is they're moving from
one position to the next to see what
will stick
because the real the real problem here
is donald trump can't run for president
again he can't
everyone keeps saying he's gonna
announce and you know he's gonna try to
use running for president to block the
doj but he can't run for president
i'm not saying he can't
you know if he wanted to but he can't
you got to remember what he's grifting
his supporters with he's grifting his
supporters with his save america pack
as soon as he announces that he runs for
president he no longer has control over
the save america pack he can't he can't
do it
he would have to give away his pack and
control to someone else
think about that for a second why would
donald trump give up his biggest money
laundering machine that he has at this
point
to go run for president again which
he'll lose
all to protect himself from prosecution
why wouldn't he just convince people to
go commit violence to stoke fear and
terrorism so that way somehow he'll be
appointed king
that way he doesn't have to run and lose
again that way he doesn't have to give
up all his is his grifting money
laundering scheme
i mean the true social was supposed to
be the next money laundering machine but
that didn't work out
he's going to lose his money laundering
machine in new york the trump
organization
tish james is going to smash that with a
[ __ ] hammer here really soon they're
supposed to test are be deposed this
week
the judge is gonna order them to be
deposed this week
so here we are here we are america
about to hear more truth
actual truth from the select committee
and it's up to you to politicize it
that's right i said it and i'll keep
saying it it's up to you pro-democracy
folks out there to go politicize the
[ __ ] out of this stuff
politicize the [ __ ] out of it all of it
the ketchup the secret service the patsy
baloney
testimony the oath keepers how they were
trying to bring bombs to the capital
politicize every [ __ ] inch of it
that's the key
we already see jd vance is down almost
10 points
from from tim ryan in ohio
that's one senate seat
we know that hershel walker is getting
his [ __ ] ass kicked in georgia
by the sitting united states senator
warnock
that's a that's a save of a seat
john fetterman is [ __ ] taking dr oz
out back and spanking his ass behind the
woodshed here and that's another
addition to the seat
that's two seats additional
to our united states senate if we can
keep and hold the house of
representatives and add two seats add
just two seats i think we can add three
but add two seats to the united states
senate
we can break the filibuster we can
codify roe v wade we can pass the voting
rights act
we can carve out
the filibuster the president united
states has already signaled that he's
willing to do that if we the people just
give him those senators he's willing to
step back and say yes carve it up [ __ ]
the filibuster
with the president's executive order the
other day that was that was his
his call his cry and now it's up to you
pro-democracy people
to go out there and engage and
politicize the ever-loving [ __ ]
out of this january 6 select committee
and the information that ensues on these
trump candidates because they've tied
themselves to trump
herschel walker dr oz jd vance every
single one of them is a [ __ ] trumper
every last one of them
eric greitens if he wins in missouri in
the primary he's a [ __ ] trumper
they're all trumpers
they've they've tied the [ __ ] weight
around their ankle and dove in headfirst
so let's make sure
that we tie plenty of cinder blocks to
it and get rid of trumpism once and for
all
that's that should be your number one
goal stop talking about not giving
democrats money or democrats fault or
democrats this or joe biden shut the
[ __ ] up it's up to you it's up to you
to do this
to blame it on someone else to blame it
on the party to blame it on a single
politician is only to skirt your
responsibility to engage in democracy
that's right i'm i'm shaking my finger
at you
look inward look inward and see your
power
what you have that you can engage in
your democracy to push it forward
for equality equity
codifying roe v wade making sure that we
get back the [ __ ] rights that we had
just months ago
it's the time is now for you to engage
and politicize the ever-loving [ __ ] out
of this this is what democrats do they
always i see this everywhere democrats
are such [ __ ] they don't want to
fight they don't do this they don't do
that
you're you're the apparatus
you're the engagement you're the
politization of all this
[ __ ] what the politicians on the hill
say now's the time for us to politicize
this
we are the people we are the vote [ __ ]
those [ __ ] people that we vote for
it's us it's up to us and if we are
self-defeatist if we are self-defeatist
uh we will not make it
we have them on the run folks
they're on the run fascism is at the
front door but it is terrified terrified
that they've been discovered because
they have we've
we watched the republican party pull
back the curtain
and expose themselves for what they
truly are
and now's the time to make them pay for
it so go out there and politicize the
[ __ ] out of this grocery store your
community center your pta meetings when
you're meeting in a family barbecue or a
friend's barbecue over the weekend
politicize the [ __ ] out of this
everything's going in our favor here
alls we have to do is take advantage of
it
to save our democracy
to not
slow step into authoritarianism
and i'm gonna show you what they want
and how they want to slow step into
authoritarianism i'm going to show you
their
[ __ ] brain schemes that they have and
they keep moving the goal post and
moving the goal post and moving the goal
post
it shouldn't work with you you should
stay focused laser focused folks
on what's at stake here for our
democracy
because i say it time and time and time
again there's two things in this country
and why democrats everyone says they
suck oh democrats suck they suck at this
they suck at that oh they know blah blah
blah blah blah
the one thing that the left coalition in
this country the liberal small l
coalition in this country still hasn't
collectively figured out that there is
government and there is politics
the only way to do government which is
policy which is all the things that
everyone wants right the line items in
the bill they want to codify roe v wade
they want people to start school at
their children to start school at three
instead of five they want to make sure
you don't go broke
so you to get an education to get ahead
in this country and work into the middle
class they want to make sure you don't
go [ __ ] broke because of a medical
bill they want to make sure you can
afford housing
afford to live in this country afford a
decent [ __ ] wage all those things all
those things are policy folks we don't
get to do any of that we the people us
pro-democracy [ __ ] out here
don't get to do any of that if you don't
play politics you have to win elections
you have to have power over policy to do
policy
now's the time to engage in the politics
politicize the ever-loving [ __ ] out of
anything you can here's a good one
what about them gas prices now dummies
what are you gonna blame gas prices
plunging on biden good [ __ ] em
[ __ ] em every [ __ ] time you see
someone in the last month who's bitched
about the gas prices ask them about them
how do you like them gas prices now huh
oh let's go brandon nazis are really
gonna be pissed off
oh this is this is it this is how you do
it rub it in their faces
rub it in their faces you politicize the
[ __ ] out of it i haven't heard one
republican [ __ ] about gas prices not
[ __ ] one
not [ __ ] one hell i went to a goddamn
birthday party this weekend a kid's
birthday party my nephew not one
[ __ ] [ __ ] about gas prices not
one
i wonder why they're going in the
opposite direction that they said they
were gonna keep going
they can't blame it on him i mean if
they blamed it on biting they'd look
really [ __ ] stupid wouldn't they
we'll get him to blame it on biden
that's what you have to do politicize
the [ __ ] out of this
it is our job now
as the democratic coalition the small l
liberalism in this country to fight for
our democracy
now's the time so do it politicize the
[ __ ] out of this
and tomorrow and this week we're gonna
have plenty of stuff to politicize
plenty of stuff to politicize
after tomorrow's hearing and thursday's
hearing
you will have plenty of ammunition to go
out
and to continue to pound trumpism with
your big huge
hammer
of truth and facts
and don't stop don't let them [ __ ]
you we're gonna see a bunch of [ __ ]
about
the two thousand mules movie dinesh
diseases in the news again
yeah he's
it really is funny when an elitist is
like ow those those dirty elites
who have ivy league degrees are ruining
our country you're one of them and
you're claiming it on twitter
[ __ ] idiot
this is really stupid [ __ ]
we should call it out and politicize it
maybe these dumb [ __ ] will finally
start to realize
that they're being had for the grift
the grift the big grift i think we're
gonna find out more about the big rift
this
this week tuesday tomorrow
noon eastern
our coverage will start with our panel
the great midas touch network panel here
on the minus touch network so do not
forget to set your reminder for the new
time we will start our coverage on the
minus touch network tomorrow at noon
eastern with the minus touch network
panel texas paul now ron reagan is going
to be rejoining us david bender the
mizellas brothers and jessica denson the
trump nda killer michael cohen
the legal af crew michael popock and
karen and nipollo are going to be
joining us tomorrow for the commentary
do not miss it
so that you know exactly how to carry it
around in your pocket
to get rid of trumpism once and for all
you
you are the politization machine out
there you can engage in your democracy
you can use your ballot the way that you
need to use your ballot not just vote
but engage in democracy
stick around we will be right back right
after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking through the
[Music]
january 6 select hearings
where we will find out more and more
evidence i mean stuff that we've already
known in the news right the stuff that's
already been reported on we will get
verification
with people being deposed and testify
right out in the open public we will
also see recordings
of the depositions of folks that have
been deposed by the january 6 select
committee again don't forget to set your
reminders tomorrow's time has changed
our coverage here on the midas touch
network will start
at noon eastern nine pacific
if you're counting out on the west coast
don't forget to set your reminders so go
over to the midas touch youtube channel
that link is there the time has changed
on it so set the reminder there don't
forget to also follow us here on youtube
the tony michaels podcast
where you will catch our show every
monday through friday every single week
date nine at noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific the same time as tomorrow
the hearing starts and that's the thing
we will start our show the exact same
time
tomorrow as the hearing so tomorrow's
hearing will be our show here on the
tony michaels podcast because it airs at
our normal time don't forget to also
download our podcast
every single episode
all two hours on apple spotify google
your or your favorite directory
you can just go to your favorite or go
to thetonymichaels.com
you can find all the directories there
you can go to
podcast.tonymichaels.com as well you can
download it there
so come come join us you know everyone
um was talking about my my [ __ ] hats
over the weekend i also i want to tell
you that they've been flying off the
shelves
hats.dtonymichaels.com so if you want a
[ __ ] hat everyone's talking in the
chat the other day about it so go check
that out as well you can go to
thetonymichaels.com also you can check
out gabe sanchez
his merch store on the tonymichaels.com
uh gabe how are you this morning i'm
good how are you oh i'm doing i'm doing
fantastic i'm doing fantastic i think
it's a great it's going to be a great
week this week yeah yeah yeah i feel i
feel i feel like
we we're going to need like three hours
every day
um next week for all the [ __ ] that's
gonna happen this week right like
because we're just not gonna get to
everything there's just no i mean we
haven't been able to get to everything
just with two hours a day how do these
people these creators do it in just a
couple minutes and an hour a day or 30
minutes who
if it's not one thing it's another i
think the [ __ ] hitting the fan is just
like we're we're going like
the fan is like oscillating and it's at
high speed and it's going everywhere
have you ever ever seen one of those
ceiling fans it it sounds like it's
gonna fall off it's going so fast that's
what and and like the [ __ ] is just
slinging yeah well that's where i was
like
we're trying to clean it up as fast as
we can right on the tony michael's
podcast but it's just
yeah the hearings will you know uh you
know we'll hear more about oath keepers
proud boys i don't know what's in store
for thursday and you know if if that's
the final one or if there'll be more and
then in august like who knows right like
stuart rhodes nonsense that we're going
to deal with i know what is this going
to be
right i mean obviously it's clearly an
attempt to kind of
they i i think what they're trying to do
is make the
make the committee seem illegitimate
right you know you've got trump who's
like
um
i'm gonna waive the you know executive
privilege so you're good you're good to
go steve if you want to go testify
before the january 6 committee i think
he doesn't have executive proof right
exactly
if anyone has read the letter at the
very end it's like good luck uh with
your future ventures or whatever like
cutting ties [ __ ] you're done why i
mean here's the thing is and i
postulated this in the first 30 minutes
the reason why donald trump and steve
bannon are really kind of scared here is
because the best weapon that they have
against america finally you know
throwing trump as
trump as i'm in the trash is the
propaganda machine that is steve bannon
and his podcast right like that
propaganda machine is one of the things
really holding this whole thing this
fraud together because i actually don't
believe that the majority that there's a
large percentage now it's a large number
of people but it's a very small
percentage in this country that still
believes this garbage or still is
still willing to sit and talk about the
nonsense
you know thank thanks to the hearings
like every day that the number is moving
toward like okay
clearly that trump did something wrong
he knew what he was doing and we should
actually uh pursue some sort of criminal
charge or investigation right well i
think i think i think the projection the
country sees this projection like oh it
was stolen from me and it was really
they were trying to steal it right like
right yeah like that's the whole and the
country is sick and tired of hearing
about the last election as we approach
very quickly the next one i mean we're
just months away
from the 2022 midterm and these [ __ ]
idiots still haven't figured out that
they lost the last one like right and i
think americans aren't going to put up
with this stuff very much longer and
that's why this the hearings are so
important for the the court of public
opinion because that really is what will
kill trumpism you can lock away these
people and really steve bannon going to
prison
for for uh contempt of congress which i
think terrifies the [ __ ] out of donald
trump because that turns off his
propaganda machine exactly i mean you
you the steve bannon prison i don't
think there's anyone else to take the
altar and run
traitor tv news network like he's got
like steve bannon's got right you know i
mean just i mean it's it's that as well
as the fact of like having
uh
the possibility that you know steve
bannon might say oh screw it i'm gonna
save my own skin if i can make sure that
i don't go to jail and i can keep doing
the show or i can keep saying whatever i
want in the public you know like i you
know i wouldn't be surprised if any one
of these people you know if if you know
the kind of feet against the the coals
here
uh
to have them be like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna
i'm gonna look out for myself right
these are all selfish people these are
people who will screw over the person
next them even if it's their mother or
some family member they will do what
they can to make sure that they don't
get
uh jail time right so if steve bannon is
one of those people and he's getting the
pressure on him and he's feeling that
pressure from the contempt of congress
charges that are coming and now he's
like hey look guys guys
i will testify but it has to be publicly
whether that's done out of like a
genuine sincerity and he's like feeling
that to be like i want to say whatever i
can to make sure that the lesser charges
are given against me for the contempt of
court or congress or you know or he's
he's doing it in a in a malicious way
you know that pressure could ultimately
make him say like
yeah i don't want to go to court i want
to say as much as i can and trump's
going to be like oh [ __ ] i can't have
that happen
well i mean that
maybe there's cause for concern because
we we have watched the last few weeks
with the select hearing but not only
that we've watched real-time stuff from
the doj where they've seized devices
from jeffrey clark they seized devices
from john eastman and really
if steve bannon had any communication
inside that orbit of eastman clark trump
giuliani um even
some of the ideas that of proud boys and
oath keepers which i have a feeling
tomorrow when they start talking about
the oath keepers and proud boys steve
bannon's name is going to come up yeah i
think that's the other reason why steve
bannon is trying his best to do
something to appear now i think it's
funny because he's been on and on the
last few weeks about [ __ ] the committee
and the mini committee [ __ ] on his show
to his audience and now he looks like a
little punk ass [ __ ] to his audience
because now he's begging begging the
committee he's like let me talk to you
please right please let me talk so i
think yeah i think i think this is all
in there they painted themselves into a
into a trees in this corner here right
but i mean i mean this is of their own
doing so
and hopefully it is the undoing of some
of this trumpism stuff and and no one
can carry that mantle forward that's my
fear is that fascism is really already
out underneath the rock
in this country and
you're gonna have folks like greg abbott
who
today uh texans you know they're uh
aircod uh our archot aircon how do you
say it down there ercot ercod i don't
believe this time is energy reliable
sorry energy reliability
it's basically the private company who
runs the power grid in texas because
texas thinks they're you know
immediately you know capitalism and
private entities and those
republicans would be republicans right
right republicans making sure that a few
a handful of people get all the profits
so they'll siphon that profit to their
political campaigns is always a a great
tenant of republican ideals um but
texans are being asked this morning turn
turn off your air conditioning basically
because we've got to conserve power
because our power grid sucks right we
and we made sure it sucks and we knew it
sucked two years ago and we still
haven't done anything about it like
right i mean when that when the um
when the kind of cold that that winter
storm came through and that's when you
know ted cruz flew out to cancun
during that time i i started doing some
research into into ercot right and i was
like you know does this happen normally
i mean outside of the winter kind of um
snafu uh we'll call it uh but i did i
did want to know like is this something
that normally happens and the rolling
brownouts is something that is a regular
occurrence right that is something that
is not new i i forget i've you know it's
like a handful of days which is already
unacceptable if you're gonna have a
company that is called the energy
reliability council of texas it should
probably be reliable right i don't know
that's just an assumption maybe so when
you hear them say things like turn off
the ac and all the stuff you're like
this is this is something that's not new
you know especially in areas of texas
that are not
uh urban
the areas that are rural out in the air
like that don't get as much attention
they experience more brownouts
throughout the year or more blackouts
throughout the year than the areas that
are more
uh condensed or concentrated that are
urban
but no one really talks about that stuff
it was only when it really impacted high
traffic areas like austin and dallas
houston all these other places where
energy shut down and people were not
able to
uh uh get the heat and electricity they
needed during the snowmageddon right but
also during the the summer when it gets
[ __ ] hot you know thanks to climate
change
temperatures are going up
and to
to stay cool right you need electricity
you need energy and they don't have the
reliability
of the energy council wait wait wait
wait wait
it sounds like they should change their
name almost uh yeah a couple people
unreliability
a couple people brought us some points
here ty says uh consumer a customer
energy bills have gone up 50
um you know where where are all the gas
price people blaming uh greg abbott for
drawing up the energy prices in texas i
want to see those people out and about
and having um having some kind of
trucker convoy of how um greg abbott has
drawn up energy prices in texas by 50
and now here here's the thing
is that
texas has a chance to change this
um and what i mean by that is to
actually do the whole i don't know
democracy thing and actually go out and
engage in their democracy and get people
registered to vote
and get better aurora i mean that's your
best chance to change this power grid
situation in texas i mean if that is
your number one focus because here's the
thing in texas right now
they spent the last two years trying to
figure out how to make sure to regulate
the [ __ ] out of a woman's body so much
so that she doesn't have rights and
there's bounties on her body
but [ __ ] the power grid [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we don't
we don't need air
i mean i've been in texas and i've been
in texas during the the summer and it's
hotter than a [ __ ] um i mean
they pretty much rely on some some air
conditioning than in that son of a [ __ ]
so you would think that they would have
you know i don't know focused on how to
fix the power grid a little longer than
they focused on a woman's uterus but
that's just me that's just me maybe so
i think if your priority in texas is to
make sure
that you have reasonable [ __ ] policy
rather it be
not [ __ ] telling people what to do
with their bodies or not to do with
their bodies
and having you know the the ability to
not have rolling blackouts
because it's hotter than the son of a
[ __ ] right i mean if you really do want
to
to have that maybe maybe you should
engage in your democracy because that's
the way you change it again i've talked
about this in the first 30 minutes and
we'll continue to talk about it there's
two things here there's government and
policy
which the republicans have made sure the
policy is to give away all the [ __ ]
energy to private industry and they
control it and no one else can tell them
what to do and it [ __ ] the entire
system up when you have like
snowmageddon someone said earlier i
think it was uh midas margie said
snowmageddon or you have the situation
where they can't turn on their air
conditioning right
and that's policy but you don't get to
control policy until you control
government so you have to play politics
so in texas if you're in texas and you
want to engage with the voters you want
to engage with your ballot your ability
to participate in the democracy
politicize the ever-loving [ __ ]
out of this situation politicize it in
every moment where you're at in texas
it's time it's time to do that because
the only way to change it is to actually
put the people who don't
want this nonsense where they only have
their own power grid and they're only
relying on this one [ __ ]
company to provide power and actually
get a common sense
a common sense power grid in texas jesus
christ states all around would be would
welcome to sell energy to taxes at a
time why the [ __ ] wouldn't they want to
sell energy to texas they would love to
sell energy to texas but they can't and
because republicans are in charge in
texas so [ __ ] change it change it to
where you don't have a bunch of [ __ ]
fascists like greg abbott and these
others controlling your power grid in
texas make sure you make your voice
heard not just to vote but engage
register the [ __ ] out of voters in texas
there are plenty of unregistered people
who are who
who can vote who need to be registered
scare the ever loving [ __ ] out of these
[ __ ] fascist republicans in texas and
in every state really
um we're going to talk more about it
here in a bit when we go to the [ __ ]
list roundup
but holy moly
have you seen some of these races john
fetterman is absolutely beating the ever
living [ __ ] at the doctor oz
good good i i hope i can find the video
he actually hired a blank doctor oh yeah
i saw him have a good day on the
campaign trail and he went back home to
new jersey and john fetterman paid to
have an airplane
fly over his house and need his mansion
in new jersey and basically telling him
to you know to take a nap and take it
easy after a hard day on the campaign
trail john fetterman i i i tell you what
love hate him whatever i like his brand
of democratic politics if no one's
paying attention to what he's doing um
then you need to because john fetterman
again love him hate him whatever
he is the type of brand that everyone
who's out there saying democrats don't
fight hard enough and all this [ __ ]
that's the brand of politics that we
have tim ryan's doing the same thing in
ohio and he's almost got 10 points on jd
vance at this point um
and i believe it's because jd vance has
wanted to run around the state talking
about [ __ ] porn and condoms and
people aren't interested in talking
about porn and condoms they want to know
about real [ __ ] that affects them yeah
you know like their [ __ ] jobs the
[ __ ] manufacturing in ohio they want
to talk about they don't want to [ __ ]
hear about some [ __ ]
used to be hillbilly who turned into a
goddamn
west coast east coast elitist to come
tell them what the [ __ ] is and what
isn't in ohio they want a real person
and it's the same thing in pennsylvania
and this is what trumpism has delivered
to ohio the republican party and
pennsylvania is candidates
who run around
talking about how elitist are the
problem and they're the [ __ ] elitist
it it begs
to see the mind so that leads me because
i know you want to talk about dinesh
d'souza i know you want to talk about it
so let's i am i am inching
rationing right now ah let's let's get
into it let's go to the shitless roundup
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the journey
michael's podcast we have reached the
part of the show where we round up all
the tweety tweets and the 20 trendy
trends in the [ __ ] list roundup
oh baby i tell you what there's a lot of
video to get to but this this uh
this this twitter battle it started with
um
major richard ojeda
he tweets something about 2000 mules
and it really does i mean
dinesh d'souza gets totally [ __ ] butt
hurt yeah over this tweet here's the
tweet from uh ojeda here
if you think the movie 2000 i like how
he puts the yeah like like
[Laughter]
like i would have also put movie in
questions right that's what i would i
would have moved the quotes over to
movie uh is valid but they're valid i
mean you use that the whole thing is in
quotes right just every word it air
quotes if you think
right right
well i mean if you
think
the movie it's just it just it can't get
any better than this uh richard ojeda
says if you think the movie 2 000 mules
is valid
you may be part of the poorly educated
which again i think he's trying to point
out here look if you're listening to
this nonsense and believing this you're
just believing it because it's what you
want to believe not because it's real
like this is just trumpism
i mean he also could you know he could
be hitting a dig at trump who said i
love the poorly educated well i think
he's doing a couple things here but yeah
that that's part of it um but the the
best part about the whole tweet
is uh dinesh d'souza that [ __ ]
elitist bonehead because that's what he
is
he
this guy is always knocking on the
leftist elites and the elites and this
and that and that's what's destroying
our country here he is
so
he really gets butt hurt
that ojeda basically said dinesh d'souza
is
is is uh
just playing to the poorly educated here
with his movie
2000 mules right
so d'souza gets really pissed off here
and says let's compare your education
and credentials to mine oh oh not
elitist at all
what's really funny about this
is jeddah is a retired army major
this guy's a veteran right yeah he ran
for office
in west virginia i believe
um he's he's a very smart individual
he's not dumb he knows politics
but he's not he's not an elitist um he's
educated but he's not an elitist he
doesn't appear that way he talks normal
he doesn't talk down to people uh a jedi
punches up he doesn't punch down
um as we
we continue to see this type of [ __ ]
but here is here is dinesh d'souza
punching down on a veteran
basically saying i'm an elitist because
he goes on to say ivy league graduate
from dartmouth of course that's what's
trending is dartmouth
policy analyst at the reagan winehouse
research scholar i love that
and a e i and the hoover institute at
stanford not elite at all right or also
the fact that he's using his
undergraduate degree he got a bachelor's
of art like a ba
from dartmouth
right this guy how old is dinesh right
now dinesh is
61 years old and he's still
leaning
on his undergraduate degree okay right
at this point you would think oh well
you know what i'm sure i did this but
maybe you want to bring up you know you
if you got an mba or you got a a
master's or you got a phd like those
things are great but
undergrad you're you're you're bragging
about your undergrad and you're 61.
that tells me you don't have a lot to
your name it's a little it's little dick
energy let's see oh yeah
i really i really find it interesting
that an an actual elitist i'm a two-time
college dropout myself
and i i don't know those are things
we'll put on wikipedia right yeah [ __ ]
yeah let's put that on the wick i'm a
two-time college dropout right so it
really it really does speak to this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that trumpism continues
to do where it's this blue collar
billionaire blue collar elitist type
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here with this
garbage you're you're claiming here in
this tweet to be the elite of the elite
of the elite and that's why everyone
should listen to you and you continue
continue to yammer on about how the left
elitist tell you what to think and you
shouldn't believe it like what the [ __ ]
are you it's projection 101 it's
trumpism 101
it's a bunch of nonsense and and just
vile garbage because he goes on to say
author of more than a dozen highly
acclaimed best-selling books
now you go what what is hilarious about
the dozens of highly acclaimed
best-selling books is he bought he
bought the books to make them
best-selling see that's how it works in
the book game and that's how a bunch of
these [ __ ] boneheads that don't know
[ __ ] their ass from a hole in the
ground end up having best-selling books
as they publish it and then they bought
they get big money to buy up a bunch of
books right so it's best selling yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here but also and
well i'll wait for this once i
want to go to the my response yeah so so
gabe i'm getting close there 8 200 8200
what's he have right now man you are you
are at 96.76 he had a 6 000 he had a 6
000 uh like head start i just want to
point that out there all right and this
over over the last 18 hours ago like it
started i was like i probably won't get
much and then last night i really took
off i'm just saying he had a huge ass
head start on this and probably because
i really tweeted it it's probably
because
it's probably what it is yeah right i
mean
or i mean i'll take i'll take whatever
or maybe maybe i don't i don't know i
didn't go to seth's account did seth say
something about it maybe that that maybe
maybe maybe he might have he might have
unblocked me and quote tweeted himself
do not talk about people who are college
educated meanwhile he's probably got a
14 million thread
twitter thing is going on to say how i
am how this tweet is dangerous right
it's it is dangerous my mind is
dangerous your tweet is dangerous to
democracy uh here we'll read the
dangerous tweet gabe says dinesh you're
a fallon who pled guilty to illegal
campaign contributions bill barr
the former attorney general i added that
part debunked your voter fraud
mockumentary and laughed at it like
literally he left
it's so stupid all while under oath
meaning he only could tell the truth by
law
you want to count and when and when
you're not telling to
you're not trying to sell your fantasy
novels
you're hawking my pillow merch that says
it all sit down bud
is what gabe says so
go go ratio the [ __ ] out of dinesh
d'souza with the other thing here is he
so his deal with
michael and dellas they
they uh
they basically
use each other to make their sales so
dinesh will promote my pillow march and
then he'll say if you buy this or if you
buy my book then you get free my pillow
merch
if you do my pillow you get this book so
it says cross cross promotion it sound
and and i'm not saying it's fraud
but
i am saying that they are using this
kind of referral incentivized program to
artificially inflate the sales
of said products like his book so what
you're saying is possibly you know
because we had dakota adams on he said
last week that if the right if a bunch
of right wingers these talking heads
were investigated um they would prob
you'd probably find out that they were
committing tax fraud that sounds like
kind of like what you're maybe saying
there i mean i don't know i mean all
these people run in the same circles and
they're always like how do i
make as much money as i can uh and use
these loopholes and then you find out
that they're actually doing illegal
stuff which is surprising because it
takes one to no one right
it it does take a lot to know these
boneheads
um speaking
speaking of more bonus i get
more to show you here um
if i can find it yeah this one here from
wu-tang is um
is for children this this this tick-tock
oh yeah [ __ ] weird man
um
they give the commentary here when they
say it's not a cult yeah that's [ __ ]
weird this is [ __ ] weird
now i i'm all for patriotism right and
hanging the flag out the way it's
supposed to be hung
and really honestly i believe that in
patriotism lives the ability to burn the
flag when you want to you know protest
against your country against and against
the actual flag itself that i think
that's patriotism our our our men and
women in war have fought for those
rights we have those rights and i think
we should continue to have these rights
and really honestly these people have
the right to do this
but it's really weird that they worship
this flag the way that they're
worshiping because it's not like they're
holding their hands over their heart and
saying the pledge of allegiance or
standing for the national anthem to be
patriotic they are literally worshiping
the signal on the flag and this is why
you know trump kind of ruined the flag
for a lot of people yeah like a lot of
people who were proud to hang the
american flag out in front of their
their house on their porch trump really
ruined it because of these [ __ ]
deplorable pieces of [ __ ] doing really
really weird
un-american things like you're about to
see let's watch this i mean we've got
well first off we've got one flag that's
made out of wood like two by fours or
something like that and then you've got
a flag hanging off that thing right it's
really weird but watch what happens with
this family because there's another flag
involved here
watch this
hey guys
by the way i'm going to turn the music
off so we're not knocked
yeah and to get this turned up but let's
listen
so you watch as the family comes and
they kneel and it's saying hey god it's
some kind of religious song
and they kneel as they're going to pray
to the flag
this is weird as [ __ ] i i want to point
out
that no what are they doing right there
they kissing um i i think so i think
they kiss yeah
okay and then he drapes the flag over
his family
and is it touching the ground it's
touching the goddamn ground well you
know
well the other thing too is it's draped
over them as which is not a thing that
you're supposed to do with the flag
either right i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
i actually think cut the [ __ ]
american flag up and make goddamn
underwear out of it if you want to
that's your right that's your freedom um
you know but if these people love the
constitution right right as they say
they do then they're going against what
it says in terms of how the the flag is
handled right right i mean again i i
actually i i don't have a lot of
sentiment about the flag itself i think
it represents our democracy
but i think also that the actual act of
how you use the flag could represent how
you think about the democracy and this
is really this is authoritarian fascist
type stuff where you're [ __ ]
worshiping i mean they're praying to the
flag it's weird as [ __ ] here right weird
[ __ ] um but this is kind of trumpism as
a whole is they they really
misinterpret what patriotism is they
misinterpret what the country means what
the constitution actually is they get
this [ __ ] all turned around and confused
they really [ __ ] do yeah but one clip
i want to show here
let's see yeah let's
oh my god this is hilarious have you
watched this i have not watched the d i
don't have the no not sorry yeah i don't
have discovery plus i haven't watched it
yet yeah i i can't i can't say that
because i don't have the
is it paramount plus a discovery plus
it's discovery plus oh okay i thought i
had it i thought i thought i had it with
bundles this apparently is out on
discovery plus i'm not paying we don't
get any money for discovery plus here if
you got discovery plus you can go watch
this a lot of people have mixed feelings
about this i guess the first three parts
of it i don't know if it's like a
six-part thing or some [ __ ]
it's only a three-part thing
wow
well some people were saying the first
part second part third part i don't know
i haven't watched it yeah um this is the
uh this is
i love the the freeze frame here um this
is from the uh
the documentary
that alex holder
that we now know is uh the raw footage
is evidence at the january sixth select
hearing
um the documentary is called
unprecedented um which is hilarious
but this is a clip that he posted
yesterday um of the documentary and i
think it's just to advertise it right
it's just to promote it yeah yeah
because i think what the the caption in
his says like orange you glad it's
premiere day yeah yeah yeah yeah if you
look here at the tweet it's orange
orange you glad it's premiere day which
is perfect for this clip um of course we
know
the cheeto dust mobster and the reason
why i call him the cheeto dust mobster
is because
he's orange but watch he doesn't appear
to know which is hilarious but he does
not appear to know that he looks why he
looks orange
watch this clip it's [ __ ] great okay
[Music]
can we get the orange out please
at first when i first stopped this i'm
like is there oranges sitting in a
basket did he really i know that's what
i i really [ __ ] with because
they had the last clip that they shared
which is with the water and the table so
i thought the same thing when i was like
oh what is he talking about like a
literal orange right like they had a bed
wouldn't that be hilarious
though with this [ __ ] to put a
basket of oranges
to have the the color and get the color
to where he looks the same as the
oranges that would be [ __ ] hilarious
what a gag that would be but he's
talking about because he's again we
watched gabe said we watched the video
where he's talking about the water and
the table
and he's looking at the monitor the
whole time this guy is a [ __ ] fraud
he's full-on he's a full-on fraud he
cares nothing about anything but his
image that's the only thing he cares
about that's why it's
still
it boggles my mind that his supporters
think he's some kind of god and they
love him because he only loves himself
but what he's doing here is he's looking
at the monitor when you when you do a
production like this and you have these
cameras they will have a monitor that is
a feed monitor that's showing what is
going to be recorded right and he's
looking at the monitor to see how he
appears
inside that feed and he's worried about
the coloring of it now remember this is
being recorded
and it's being recorded raw
so a lot of that footage can be changed
you know the coloring and footage can be
changed and stuff to a degree but he's
really worried because he thinks this is
like live or something he's got to right
yeah i don't know i mean like who knows
he's oh that's great great great i mean
like i i could imagine that when he's
watching this normally he's like oh yeah
that looks great that looks great cool
okay we're ready to go let's do it you
know uh but i i mean maybe he maybe he's
like this is uh he's they say this is a
live feed
of what the you know what's recording so
maybe
i don't but i don't know i can't figure
this out you think a guy who's done this
much [ __ ] in front of a camera would
know this but
what he's doing here
is he is looking at the monitor he's not
looking at a camera he's looking at the
monitor how he looks
so let me back it up here and show you
again when this fat [ __ ] sits down you
can see
he's looking at the monitor and he's
talking not about a oranges because you
can see there's no oranges in the shot
here
well there's one there's a big orange
there's a big one well right right
right but he he's not talking about a
basket of oranges right shot he's
talking about his [ __ ] face watch
this
[Music]
can we get the orange out please
it would have been funny if there was
just a huge [ __ ]
in the show right right
we i i i don't think you should take
this and do that at all okay yeah right
whoops
let me just download
one more time one more time
can we get the orange out please
it's very orangey
i don't know
i don't know why that is he says i would
even go as far as to say like if i had
um
if i actually had an orange costume
that would be something where i would
just be like
you know just green screen myself in
brings up a good point and you know um
he may he may be wearing a lot of orange
soon and may not be able to get the
orange out
um but again alex holder with the joke
here says orange
orange glad it's premiere day
oh boy oh boy with the dad joke
everyone loves a good dad joke you know
from one
from two you know
to trump the
the maga daddy as they call him
the maga daddy king oh my god okay so if
you can go watch on discovery plus
please please come in the comments
and give us your take on the
on the documentary i apparently it's you
know it was supposed to be a fluff piece
on the family
is what i it's what i gathered
and it it turned into something
different because they're it's not their
family's not very fluffy as it were
right if that makes sense
i guess just it's just not very fluffy
um
with how you would make the footage look
now the raw footage is part of the
january 6 elect committee evidence i
wonder if we're going to see some of
that evidence maybe tomorrow or thursday
what do you think like that part of the
footage like the raw like the stuff yeah
yeah i think it is
yeah i probably would imagine thursday
if to unless there's something that was
recorded or like captured in the
documentary
i'm gonna have to say it's probably
gonna be thursday because tuesday's
gonna be more of like who the proud boys
are who the oath keepers are their
history and what their role was
and if i had to imagine it would be
showing the documentary footage on
thursday there is a follow-up on there's
a follow-up clip that somebody has oh
you got a problem you got a link here
yeah yeah yeah throw that in there let's
let's go make fun of this [ __ ]
yeah it's about don jr so why not
perfect yeah uh is that where he's
speaking on stage saying [ __ ] and then
no no no no no that's this is one from
the actual documentary okay let's so
somebody had like recorded from their
phone it's just like a minute long okay
let's um oh so so this is uh this is a
ripped ripped clip perfect with clip we
like we like we like ripping off clips
here let's uh pull this in
here's
here's donnie j donnie jr you you
actually received a [ __ ] couple phone
calls from him yeah man he calls me all
the time all the time this [ __ ] guy
we'll show that we'll show that after we
get done here we'll show that phone call
that he yeah and then he was it was it
the fourth of july is the well he called
me over the fourth of july weekend and
then he also called me before that but i
think we've already shown that one but
yeah fourth of july look at the fourth
of july call but let's let's see what
donny jr booger sugar junior has to say
in the documentary here um
because i'm just willing to be like hey
guys like i'm calling [ __ ] donald
trump jr doesn't know what he's talking
about if he's trying to be a media
critic you know journalists investigated
the biden family pretty thoroughly and
reported what was true if this was a joe
biden rally and joe biden would be
talking to you
by looking at the teleprompter and i do
buy it and after 50 years of shipping
your jobs to china i'm going to change
course pause for applause
my brother's wife this weekend with jake
tapper how dare you say
my brother's wife this weekend he can't
even say her name yeah
does he know her name i don't think so
i'm sure like before he's like someone's
got to remind me her name's lara i don't
know
i mean literally he he's like my
brother's wife i don't know i don't know
what her name is yeah i don't know what
her name is but my brother's wife what
the [ __ ]
i don't even know what my brother's name
is
he probably i don't know his brother's
name's wife is i don't know my brother's
name is
just you know yeah it's like i don't
know is it is it barren probably not
barren full of coke we'll make the
medicine go down
medicine oh jesus let's let's listen
he's got mental decline the guy can't
remember where he
is oh he's stuttering
stuttering doesn't stop you from
remembering your wife from your sister
so this next part is very important and
i know it's hard to hear because this is
a recording from a cell phone but this
next part is like real important this
speaks to trumpism
and what it actually shows in this
documentary which is incredible that
they thought this was going to be a pup
piece about the family yeah and again
it's because they're not very puffy
right not very puffy and fluffy they're
[ __ ] vile so when you do a piece
about them it's vile let's watch in the
trump language and this was true of the
trump children as well
often the cruelty is the point
often the cruelty is the point that's it
that's the feature
like the feature of trumpism is the
cruelty not not the benefit of it it's
the feature it's the headline feature
is the cruelty
and it's it continues on and on and on
with this stuff
[Music]
if you can think of trumpism as
something like the opposite of virtue
signaling you know this is something
like vice signaling you don't have to be
sentimental we're going to give you
license to not care about anything and
not to have any particular conscience
exactly
don't care about anything don't have any
conscience about anything this is this
is crazy stuff because i've had family
members that fell to cuba on and i say
the word [ __ ] a lot even in front of him
and and when i say [ __ ] they're like
oh you can't say that word i'm like are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
like the vile [ __ ] that you say in the
bible [ __ ] that you spew and the people
you support and you're you're chastising
me for saying the [ __ ] f word get the
[ __ ] out of here
this
again the [ __ ] cruelty that they have
is the [ __ ] feature and and she
describes it as the opposite
of virtue signaling right right like
it's the permission to be crew it's the
permission to not have consequences and
not have conscience of what you're doing
and who you're saying it to and who it
affects right regardless of the actual
actual consequences of this stuff i mean
letting fascism crawl out underneath the
rock you know to the point of of cruelty
you know like the that's the point you
have to remember that don jr is you know
i don't know if you remember this story
but when he was at you penn
uh he walked into the you know open the
door and into his i think it was his
dorm room and then donald trump [ __ ]
slapped him across the face didn't say
[ __ ] knocked him on the floor in front
of all of his classmates and then said
put on a suit and meet me outside
like this is the person i even think
mary trump talked about how
her uncle you know donald trump's dad
was also very much the same way where it
was like
you're of no value to me
if you are not making me look good
and you are no value to me
if you are an embarrassment if you
uh you know make the family look bad
uh you know i will find out who is the
better one of the siblings obviously
clearly we've seen that she is uh or
that trump is very much the pro ivanka
in a weird kind of
greek mythology kind of way
um
but you you look at that and it's like
no wonder dude like donald trump jr eric
trump and ivanka
have all come from this broken household
that was created probably for trump and
maybe for you know donald trump's father
but it's that type of hatred it that's
the point right they're coming after you
if they can make someone else laugh
because you're the butt of the joke like
they're attacking you and you are now
the target
not to build you up but to punch you
down and
and knock you down
that's where they get that that type of
like uh
joy and fulfillment because that's what
they learned growing up that was the
only way in which you either got your
father's attention was to be on the
receiving end of something that was good
and if you weren't then it was an
embarrassment and you weren't want to do
you wouldn't want to do that again
that's the household that trump that
whole like
you know uh uh fake facade uh we've got
gold here and gold there like it's all
[ __ ] fake
and if you're an embarrassment
or you do something that goes against
the image the fake image of trump
then you're going to get a [ __ ] slap
across the face so you've learned to
attack everyone else to make yourself
look more important to build yourself up
right and that's what the trump family
does and rita puts its
great template here she says i've always
said this is what trump did gave
people a license to hate openly
and that's the truth you know this
fascism crawled out from underneath the
rock um a lot of people it crawled out
from underneath their inner being right
they already believe this stuff we see
we see christian churches in this
country chanting let's go biden and it
means our let's go brandon it means [ __ ]
joe biden and in churches they're
chanting this stuff yeah and it's code
language so they can say and look at
each other go yeah [ __ ] your biden
but that's the exact opposite there was
a clip that you posted from the weekend
oh cheeto dust mobster himself doing
this punching down thing now obviously
it's on elon musk um so he's trying to
he's trying you know he loved elon and
he hates elon he loves elon but you know
it's just it's just nonsense about
and we we said it months ago i said it
when he first said he was gonna buy
twitter i said that's [ __ ] it's all
[ __ ] he's a flake he's not gonna do it
you can't trust elon when he says
anything
yeah
and and i was correct right you know
doubt me the crystal ball thing but here
is trump
saying he knew he wasn't gonna buy
twitter which is [ __ ] that is not
what trump said that's not what trump
said trump was
wanted elon to actually buy twitter he
wanted him they even went a back and
forth of rather trump would get his
account back on twitter this is all
nonsense he did not ever believe yeah
that was also when devin nunes says
twitter's a ghost town right exactly
there's no one over there it's a bunch
of fake accounts it's a ghost town right
and it's so active over on truth social
is it so because at that time trump was
not even on there it's just a big dick
contest to these people that's all it is
is little dick energy where they whip it
out and try to measure each other let's
watch go out by the way while i'm here
and sign up now for truth social it's
hot as a pistol and you see that i pull
that one right
leon's i tell you what leons what what
does that mean it's elon
so he can't he didn't say evil he said
yeah in the moment when
and i guess there's more than one
there's more than one yeah there's
multiple lands well he's got 10 kids so
yeah and what happens let's listen to
this [ __ ] [ __ ] box
elon there you go eli
got it yeah yeah
yeah you got it you got it man you got
it move on you finally got the name
let's let's go with it twitter
when did you hear that before me from
you heard it from me [ __ ] me i
was the very first one i was on the
[ __ ] live broadcast that minute when
he said he was gonna announce to buy it
i said he wasn't going to what was that
april 24th i need to pull that [ __ ]
tape it wasn't trump it was me
shut the [ __ ] up you fat slob it was me
i was the first one the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
no it wasn't you was me from a fake
account she says fake a lot of them nah
he's got himself a mess you know he said
the other day oh i've never voted for a
republican i said i didn't know that he
told me he voted for me
so he's another [ __ ] artist but well
you're not really a republican but you
know yeah again another
i love how he calls elon a [ __ ]
right well it's just like it's just like
dinesh you know it takes one to no one
you're right right leon leon must is uh
is a leon's musk is a uh is a [ __ ]
artist apparently uh in trump's eyes i
guess again it takes one to no one
though here we go
so he's another [ __ ] artist but he's
not going to be buying it
he's not going to be buying it
although he might later who the hell
knows what's going to happen this is him
hedging his best this is him hedging
right now right he's not going to buy it
who knows maybe he'll buy now and so
then later on he'll be like i called it
you know yeah i said it i said it listen
and we can go through this elon thing if
you [ __ ] want to but the fact of the
matter remains elon musk is probably
going to lose anywhere between 16 and 28
million dollars on this deal yeah he's
not going to fork over 44 billion he
doesn't have it so let's but let's
continue with the [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] here
contract i looked at his contract not a
good contract oh yeah he's done that now
yeah we love the truth oh boy
it's doing good no it's not yeah no it's
not because he's saying it is it's not
like and let's also not forget the fact
that he's over here trying to pimp out
truth social right he's like go to chew
social go to it's going good it's hot as
a pistol
this guy
left the [ __ ] company
that owns truth social because he was
about to get [ __ ] subpoenaed seems
really hot it's hot as a pistol it's hot
as a pistol because it's hot with crime
there's a lot of crime going on here
better get out while you can get the
guys just post on there don't actually
have anything to do with the business
right you may go to federal prison right
but we but but i sent you that threat
this weekend which what you were
referring to is the 16 billion is before
everyone was like oh yeah there's a
billion dollar breakup fee whoever
whichever party decides hey you know we
don't want to go further they have to
cover the 1 billion and potentially
legal fees if the other party then comes
forward or comes after them in a lawsuit
right
well then we reveal we find out this
weekend that
the contract has been broken down like
what the actual agreement was it wasn't
just a billion
it was the performance of that company
so
elon musk agreed to pay 44 billion is 54
20 which is a 420 joke right because aha
it's all a joke
oh it is a joke yeah it's a [ __ ] joke
and the joke is on elon right right now
and the more of that right the market
value is 28 billion so the delta between
44 and 28 is 16
which means now elon musk is potentially
responsible for 16 billion dollars of a
lawsuit that he has to pay out that's
great so you know it's not just 1
billion it is now potentially six
billion they'll probably you know
they'll settle and it'll be less than
that maybe right right because here
here's what i see happening if you guys
want to know the crystal ball here's
what i see happening
the doubt me we need to make these
shirts everything yeah
yeah i know the doubt me shirts and it
just
stay tuned we'll we'll get to it we got
a lot of [ __ ] going on but we'll try to
get you some doubt me shirts but here's
the crystal ball here
twitter's definitely gonna sue elon for
sure 100 going to sue elon there's no
way they're going to let him skate on
this as soon as he announced it they
said they literally came back because
as soon as he announced it
every publication was like you know to
twitter can we get a comment and they're
like we are pursuing legal action right
right out of the game right out of the
[ __ ] it says it in the actual
contract that they can sue right
and and it's over this one million
dollar buyout thing or or walk away fee
or one billion
oh yeah one billion excuse me and one
billion because they're what they're
gonna say is it's not one billion
anymore you [ __ ] it because now the
market value is different you talk [ __ ]
about it that's right you tanked the
company in the value of the company you
built the contract right you also there
was also talks of trying to get a
renegotiated price right right which
shows like oh either you intended to
take the company the value of the
company so you could renegotiate for a
cheaper price because you realize that
5420 your 420 joke and 44 billion you
got [ __ ] cornered in for a joke that
you made in the right wing republican
conservative party they said yeah you
got to buy it free speech you got to do
it and you didn't want to back down
because you didn't you look like a
little [ __ ] and now you look like a
[ __ ] because here's what's going to
happen he's going to be a [ __ ] because
what's going to happen is twitter is
going to sue to force him to buy at 44
billion yeah they're going to force him
they're going to because
if they don't buy
these the shareholders would buy to say
that you're not actually acting in the
you're not doing the financial
responsibility that's why they're
already suing they have twitter twitter
and really this is a play by twitter and
i would imagine that twitter is probably
going to get four or five maybe six
eight billion dollars out of this deal
like they're gonna they're gonna fill
their car yeah they'll make at least at
least half or a little bit around that
for sure right so so what will happen is
because they have to sue they have to
assume that's what that's why they are
suing for the 44 billion to force elon
to buy and when and he's not going to
buy right they're just they're they're
seeking
that fee
is what well they're either seeking the
the 44 billion right or the fee in the
contract which the fee in the contract
is no longer going to be 1 billion it's
going to be about 16 billion is what the
figures are right now currently now this
will go on and on and on for years and
years so we actually won't see this
happen
it may it may take five six seven years
to settle this in court right this isn't
going to happen very fast i mean unless
elon just chunks over the change of the
st and that's what everyone's like oh
this was just a scheme to buy to sell
eight billion dollars in tesla stock i'm
like he's gonna spend that tesla stock
because he [ __ ] this up like he's
probably going to spend most that stock
he sold in tesla too [ __ ]
to make sure this deal is good because
as much as twitter had to follow the
contract so does elon
so he either has to buy twitter for 44
billion which he won't because he can't
or he has to fork over that walk away
free which is much more than one billion
now right much more than one billion and
that's what they're gonna sue him for or
for the 44 or the whatever the walk away
fee is right and he's gonna he's gonna
settle out of court so you're gonna hear
one of these days that twitter and elon
settle at a court for you know an
undisclosed amount of to walk away from
this deal and elon that way they could
both cancel this contract and it's no
longer a contract because that's the
other thing people are forgetting is
there's their stakeholders here and they
filed this paperwork officially so it
has to it has to come to an end
somewhere right this contract has to
have an end to it there has to be a
resolution to it which the resolution is
probably going to be had in court and
it's probably going to end up being a
settlement between elon musk and twitter
and elon musk is going to fork over have
a lot more than one billion dollars uh i
mean even when it was
even after like when the deal was
announced because i remember because
this weekend i went back and i was like
i was pretty petty because in the sense
of i was coming back at people that
attacked me
because on april 25th 26 or whatever i
had i was tweeting out and then on the
27th i made a post that basically said
like
um
this is how much money has this how much
is the cover that's not secure despite
you know uh one specific person in the
chat who's like it's gonna be a it's a
done deal he he solely owns the company
right he already owns it he already owns
it
and the thing being like look he's
either got this or this he's either
gonna pay the 44 billion which he
doesn't have secure or he's gonna have
to pay the one billion breakup fee that
was at that time right he's stuck
and that tweet like took off it was like
thousands of people were tweeting and
retweeting and saying like either yeah i
agree or a lot of people who a bunch of
like fintech bros and like elon stans
were saying that i didn't know what i
was talking about you're like you don't
know what you're talking about yeah
you're doing you're an idiot oh yeah i'd
love to take financial advice from a
comedian yeah you have no idea what
you're talking about when you look at
just how it works looking at the looking
at the financials and reading the
writing that's on the wall
and having these people go like oh
that's ever going to happen right and
you know looking at the market value
going down and how he doesn't fulfill
the promises he makes and how he always
attacks people after the fact so he
looks good right remember this is the
guy that said he was going to
uh he was going to help fight world
hunger
and then he's like nah if i get i'm just
gonna buy twitter right like this is the
same guy who also could have bought any
one of the gab parlor ghetto troops but
i think i think that's the point here
and that's the point here is twitter is
actually the the social media giant that
that is that is the ability to spread
a message right
the fastest way to spread the news in a
message
is twitter i mean there are other social
media giants right in the realm of
messaging twitter is where it's at now
the other thing too is that elon musk
doesn't have the money to buy twitter
he's not as rich as you want to make him
he doesn't have piles of cash laying
around in warehouses right that's not
how this works you [ __ ] idiots yeah
so he has to sell stuff to buy something
else or he has to go to the bank and
leverage the stuff that he owns and he
couldn't do that here he wasn't able to
[ __ ] make good on the joke that he
made on twitter which is the funniest
part about it right and said he made the
joke on twitter they all held his feet
to the fire he didn't want to look like
a punk ass [ __ ] so he had to pretend to
buy it because he couldn't he couldn't
just pull the 44 billion dollars out of
his ass to buy it because he doesn't
have it um speaking of people who don't
have uh brains
here is um
oh my god this is hilarious i gotta pull
the banner down to even show this this
is [ __ ] great this is lauren bowman i
can't miss those chairs in the back
there all right i call her clanny oakley
now you can see she's standing on uh a
trailer here that has a a big banner
that says
stand for the constitution so remember
that part when she says stand for the
constitution and she has a jacket and
appears or a shirt that's made from an
american flag okay
yeah she's gonna talk a lot about the
bible so really right up front this
whole fascism is going to take over our
country and it's not going to be through
bullets it's going to be
you know with
someone draping themselves with the flag
carrying the bible you know that right
adage
but the funniest part about this video i
think and i pointed this out
is all these empty chairs
now notice the distance between the
chairs and the trailer do you know why
that is gabe do you know why they put
that distance in between there
no let's pull the chairs back
let's pull the chairs back because we
want people to go up and stand there
oh standing room only okay
did people get the wrong time well i
don't know i mean the tens of people
that are there uh definitely cheered her
the people she brought with her right
yeah her family right yeah they're
cheering really loudly but the chairs
are really empty but this standing room
only in the front is [ __ ] hilarious
like this is that this is not her
rehearsing beforehand this is her
actually
this is the actual event okay
now listen to what she says here about
the constitution that she claims to love
that she wants to stand for that the
banner says listen to how she shits
on the actual constitution here listen
and i believe that great patriots all
throughout this nation
and christians will begin to position
themselves
in
okay first off it gets really hairy here
when she starts to talk about patriots
and christians and positioning
themselves um when
we all know her husband um
it whipped out his you know his wanger
and
his hot dog right and his hot dog at a
uh at a bowling alley apparently to a
bunch of underage girls um
positioning themselves or being one of
them in in the group
right and positioning themselves and
christians and
uh you know saying the word patriot
which she means
fascist here
this really is not going well even as we
start here but let's keep listening
in these days in these times the pastors
would have a boldness to speak from the
pulpit of their churches to direct and
inform the church she's saying a lot of
words to make her sound smart
do you notice that like she like i asked
you privately i was like do you think
she rehearses this [ __ ] in front of a
mirror oh yeah i think i think she's in
the bathroom
with her paper she says her three
because she the way that she delivers
her word like her her statement is is in
three words she's like and here i stand
before you now
with the i think it's only because she
can do three words at a time i think so
well i think they're just big letters
right big font on there and so she's
going through
for someone who would who attacks other
who says like end quote repeat the line
which by the way i saw a video that was
a compilation earlier this morning which
was of all fox and
trump court like uh like people that
were giving speeches and they all said
stuff like end quote repeat the line so
i feel like for you mean out of the
teleprompter out of the teleprompter
yeah or even written down they repeat it
you know yeah um but i think she's one
of the same people that probably have it
really big she's like emphasis is key i
have to say it like this
because that's how people can digest it
right right and i don't know if that's
just a comprehension or whatever but i
don't think i mean she you know i don't
know her attempt whenever she does her
like those fake committee hearings or
like those fake committee members she's
like reading off the ipad and she's
trying to give her two cents and be like
i know what i'm talking about it's not a
teleprompter gabe it's an ipad right i
know i know i know but i it's just one
of those things where it's like yeah she
most definitely 100 practices in front
of a mirror probably sits her kids down
jason in the recliner easy boy pull it
back
and she's rehearsing as she like paces
back and forth and she does that thing
too she does the pacey thing now she
can't do it here
because she's on a livestock trailer
apparently i don't know exactly why they
chose this type of trailer actually this
looks like a dump a dumpster
do you know that this looks like this
it could be no it looks it looks like a
dump trailer so like um you know when
they're when they're hauling trash oh
yep yeah yeah yeah because they gotta
dump it you know right they gotta dump
the trash she just drove she drove this
thing onto some some child's playground
children's playground to be like this is
where i'm gonna give my speech right
from up from a [ __ ] she's like look
if there's anyone if there's anyone out
there who or like any place i can go
where there's going to be more people
than just like wandering around it's
going to be these kids i'm going to
indoctrinate these kids i'm going to get
their parents to cheer on sit down you
know we're going to have a grill out
later you know we're going to stand for
the constitution i mean if she could get
people to [ __ ] show up she can't even
get people to [ __ ] show up to this
trash yeah and you know i guess it's uh
you know it's very i mean i wonder if
that's her husband in the background
there yeah but probably is he's kind of
hiding so we can't see his winger right
well it's a squirt gun oh kid in the
front is a squirt gun
yeah are you talking about this this guy
right here yeah yeah he's holding a
squirt gun
but let's listen to how she says
churches should have influence let's
listen
the pastors would have boldness to speak
from the pulpit of their churches to
direct and inform the church on how to
influence the direction
of government
she uses a lot of big words that she
doesn't appear to know if she's
influenced the direction of government
she wants the church so no longer you
know as a separation it's a union
you're going to make you know
one one church one state you know that's
how the bible intended it right yeah
that why i mean it doesn't say anything
in the constitution right about freedom
of religion at all exactly like it
doesn't say that at all
it's it's as if it's as if it's as if it
eludes them that people came here to i
don't know uh get away from what is it
called religious persecution that's one
of the reasons why some of the folks
came here it's right really [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] there's a whole revolution you know
they're like
what revolution we're like hey guys we
wanna we wanna not be associated with
you you know we wanna we wanna have a
war here
to make sure that we have an
independence from you
it's crazy attendance independence
revolution
this sounds familiar um i want to show
you
speaking of um i don't know what i'm
speaking of here
i'm trying to do a transition here again
next video a pete buddha judge mayor
pete now the secretary of transportation
goes on fox news sunday have you watched
this clip yeah i have yeah i've watched
it several times god you know
pete buddha judge is so good at slam
dunking the best part is the host is
trying to cut in to get him to stop
saying the [ __ ] that he's saying
pete gives no [ __ ] yeah he's like skip
a beat yeah he's like i'ma let you
finish but
he just keeps continuing on with his
point slam dunks at home and i'm so i'm
so
s it it it really warms my heart when
pete buddha judge goes on fox news and
they just still
don't get that he's going to [ __ ]
slam dunk them like they continue
we're going to get pete this time
right no no you're not no you're not
let's listen here to pete buddha judge
absolutely dunk whoever this is this a
guy who's who was hired to fill in for
chris wallace uh maybe i don't even know
who this guy is this guy what is this
guy let's listen your husband tweeted
after
uh justice brett kavanaugh left a
washington restaurant due to protesters
the tweet reads sounds like he just
wanted some privacy to make his own
dining decisions
which is hilarious by the way that's a
great justin budda just let me read that
again the tweet was because the context
here is that uh brett kavanaugh was
really sad and morton's defended him as
people would shout outside and he was
forced to not eat steak with his ketchup
um at morton's and he had to run away
scared because he [ __ ] took away
people's rights and when he said he
wasn't going to when he when he
testified before the senate uh
confirmation you know when asked for a
quote brett kavanaugh said i like steak
i like beer and i like steak
so what's wrong with that they made me
they made me stop eating my steak and
drink my beer he likes to cry in beer so
i don't know yeah and that's what
happens a lot of tears in the beer but
uh but pete bridge's husband here jason
um it says it perfectly about the
situation about brett kavanaugh sounds
like he just wanted some privacy to make
his own dining decisions alluding to
that hey you [ __ ] idiot you want
privacy but you're going to take it away
right from people's bodily autonomy [ __ ]
you get the [ __ ] out here you can have
your cake and eat it too right that's or
your steak and eat it oh yeah you can't
even
look at that listen listen to pete's
response here it is beautiful
is that appropriate sir
look when uh public officials go into
public life we should expect two things
one you should always be free from
violence harassment and intimidation and
two you're never going to be free from
criticism or peaceful protest people
exercising their first amendment rights
and that's what happened in this case
remember the justice never even came
into contact with these protesters they
reportedly didn't see or hear them
and these protesters are upset because a
right an important right that the
majority of americans support was taken
away not only the right to choose by the
way but but this justice was part of the
process of stripping away the right to
privacy as long as i've been alive
settled base law in the united states
has been that the constitution protected
a right to privacy and that has now been
thrown out the window by justices
including justice kavanaugh who as i
recall swore up and down
in front of god and everyone including
the united states congress in front of
god and everyone that is oh my god that
is [ __ ] fantastic literally the
people who claim to be such great
christians and that's the reason why we
have to get rid of women's bodily
autonomy
swore their hand on a bible and swore to
god that they would tell the truth and
all that [ __ ] and they lied they
lied and it is now
evident more than ever that they lied
and they're worried about their privacy
let's continue that they were going to
leave settled case law alone so yes
people are upset they're going to
exercise their first amendment rights
and as long as that's peaceful that's
protected compare that for example
to the reality that as a country right
now we're reckoning with the fact that a
mob summoned by the former president all
right well let me follow up mr
united states capital for the purpose of
overthrowing the election and very
nearly succeeded in preventing the
peaceful transfer of power but i think
common sense can tell the difference but
as a high-profile public figure sir are
you comfortable with protesters
protesting when you and your husband go
to dinner at a restaurant now this is
great because uh again pete didn't let
this guy interrupt when he was trying to
get him to shut down not to talk hey
don't don't talk about the violent
insurrection that republicans you've
wrought on our country don't try to talk
about how donald trump trying to
overturn our government become the
dictator don't talk about that here on
fox news pete doesn't give two [ __ ] he
continues and says exactly what he wants
to say but listen to pete's response
here when this guy is asking him about
how he would respond
peacefully outside in a public space
sure look i can't even tell you the
number of spaces venues and scenarios
where i've been protested and the bottom
line is this any public figure should
always always be free from violence
intimidation and harassment but should
never be free from criticism or people
exercising their first amendment rights
and again there you go it's called i
don't know democracy
democracy so get over it get over it
brett kavanaugh
get over it uh and and
your husband tweeted eat your steak at
home is what you should do eat your
steak at home speaking of people who
should lay off
lay off the ketchup on their steak um
i'm i'm really and the transitions are
great today aren't you yeah no i well
here i thought you were going to go from
that one to this one from the last one
because you talked about independence
and i was like oh that's a clear
indicator of where you're going from
there well
no no ketchup on the steak here
well see here's here's the thing is
here's why i transitioned this way
because
my comment to this video about mike
glendale that we're about to watch
because we're about to watch a clip of
mike lindell
with all kinds of [ __ ]
word salad here um
trees in this word salad i said jesus
christ does he eat the stuffing from the
pillows like literally this guy has just
got something wrong with his [ __ ]
brain i mean we
i think in this in this
clip he talks about the money
no no he's talking what he's talking
about well he may i don't know why he's
not the one where he talks about he's
like i made you know which is the one
where he was like in the first six
months i made this much money because i
was wondering this is the one this is
the one where he's talking about how
he's gonna [ __ ] have the biggest
event oh everyone oh right yeah that's
this one that's this one springfield
missouri and then he follows it up with
a bunch of [ __ ] word salad
listen like this is not a very long
there's too many of these clips man well
that is mike lindell this is so exciting
because
it's just all going to lead up everybody
too and i've got to say this
he's always got to say this like he he
always leads in with i gotta say this
it's like me saying you know giving a
transition you know my shitty transition
this guy's always like i gotta say this
like yeah no [ __ ] mike lindell you're
gonna say something yeah you got a
microphone you're on tv saying something
you have a network
right you're going to continue to frank
speech.com my god this [ __ ] guy
listen
august 20th and 21st the biggest event
this country in our lifetime i believe
it's the most important event you're
ever for
in our lifetime in the history of ever
ever gabe it's the largest biggest cur
incredible spacious
if you thought the last
cyber symposium was great
get a load of this one remember the last
event i had that changed history and
changed the world and and you know
actually made people get criminal
prosecutions what's funny about the last
cyber symposium that you're talking
about is
the the [ __ ] county clerk or whatever
it is from colorado in lauren bobert's
district where she apparently had goaded
this person to go [ __ ] with voting
machines
um she is now under criminal prosecution
did you know that yeah
the secretary of state is like whoa
there's something fishy about this they
went and checked into it they were
[ __ ] with the voting machines of
course
of course they're [ __ ] that's the
same lady you remember during the cyber
symposium this [ __ ] this pebble
stuffed idiot was talking about
how he had this special guest that was
gonna rock the world and gonna change
everything she's on a plane they had to
fly her on a plane because they were
trying to arrest her and all kinds of
[ __ ] do you remember that and then she
came to cyber symposium that's that lady
that's that lady that is now under
indictment i forget what her name is
um well it's also
also in that time it was uh
what's his face what's his face from uh
q anon on
running d has to hear from facebook her
name is tina peters that's what tina
peters got okay well you also had um
uh
hold on hold on i'm blanking on the name
right now yeah see we know you know we
we admit when we don't know things yeah
yeah uh
but tina peters yeah see ty's got it and
everyone's saying tina peters right
right and amanda who's the who is that
why am i blanking on his name right now
queuing on he's running in arizona now
oh you're talking about uh watson yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so they had
yeah if you remember last year they had
ron watson come on the screen
and they were trying to show the data
about how the whole
election was rigged and it had uh fake
ballots and this and that oh yeah during
the cyber symptoms yeah during the
cybersync then ron was like what are you
guys doing like any and then he [ __ ] on
it later and he was like this is
he's like this is so poorly put together
right well i mean well it is it is the
mypella gay let's continue to listen
here it's very difficult after this part
because he's really not saying anything
he says it's in springfield missouri but
he does i i can't understand what the
[ __ ] he's saying
it's actually kind of hilarious i don't
know you tell me i mean you're not going
to watch these people yeah they are a
parody of themselves let's watch because
it's hilarious what this is going to do
yeah this will be in springfield
missouri live stream to the world
and it's a two-day event it's invite
only you guys will be there yeah you
said that it's an invite so it's in
spring it's free from missouri yeah
springfield
he's trying to keep him on track
he's like where are you going man where
are you going okay we're
going to invite only got it so you want
to make sure that it's limited so that
you can say only 50 people were invited
and 50 people showed up it's limited
it's very exclusive that's what you're
trying to make here
so it's uh man you know but yeah he very
much is like all right let's keep on
track yeah so you said it was invite
only we're invited right it's gonna
happen in springfield missouri let's
keep this [ __ ] thing going all right
let's get we got we only got we only got
30 minutes here mike we can't stand here
and talk for six hours about your
eight-hour new cyber emposium let's
finish that's right it's so important
yeah you'll be if you know the invites
will be going out these will be
influencers podcasters grass roots
what
gas roots gas rates are great so yeah
he's trying to save his roots here yeah
gasoline to be fair he's he's from the
north right so they got he's got an
accent
grass roots now that's the way we would
say it
and that's why you would say it in like
springfield missouri you'd say grass
roots he's speaking of the people can't
you can't you hear it
i guess so but he said gas ruts okay
let's let's listen to more gas rights
talk let's see what other words hell
this guy's got for us it'll be uh
church leaders okay and when we do this
everybody imagine every state will be
getting up there saying uh you know
here's our footprint you're all gonna
hear what what state every state
footprint what is this every state it
look tony it's a it's a gas roots
movement okay
okay and they have a foot every state
has a foot everywhere look every gas
roots movement has a foot and there's
two feet and there's 50 states so
there's like at least a hundred feet for
this gas roots movement
and it's gonna be a movement you know
it's gonna be a movement i'm having a
little bit of a bowel movement you know
and so it's a movement movement
like uh
church leaders
it's a foot and a grass roots and look
at any point at any point people are
gonna stand up on those feet that god
gave them and they're gonna say hey this
is what's going down in our state
because it's a grassroots movement oh
this [ __ ] guy let's let's finish it's
it's it's it gets even funnier it keeps
being funny i wish this clip was like
six minutes long it would be great yeah
the good going where's our hope you know
and then the next day will be everything
of uh of what what each state can do
individually to get to where this is
what
i know oh i can't these [ __ ] guys
these are what what each state can do
individually look i'm pretty sure that
all of these states i think the end was
like 63 and 0 or something like that in
terms of court cases or oh and 63 depend
how you look at it but these people mike
lindell rudy giuliani donald trump all
these dumb [ __ ] jeffrey clark also
there should be a video out tomorrow
about jeffrey clark it'll be the uh the
extended
body cam footage
of him in front of his home oh okay well
we'll watch for that piece of green yeah
i will definitely make sure to label it
as
not
the actual footage
for a certain individual right well you
know um we don't want to piss anyone off
we don't want them to think that we're
not an ally of democracy here oh my god
all they'd have to do is go do a little
bit of i don't know research if you were
a journalist you're such a great
journalist and researcher maybe you
should do a little bit of it um here's
another dumb book okay oh my god this
[ __ ] guy what what
you know i can't even imagine because we
heard the story a couple weeks ago that
ronnie jackson we know he was the white
house physician this is the drunk ronnie
jackson oh my god this is a guy that
said trump was like a hundred pounds in
the health yeah he said he was the
healthiest president ever
i don't know how drunk ronnie was at the
time when he wrote that
but now now now now put it in contest
because ronnie jackson was also in the
white house as the physician for for the
very end of george w bush and barack
obama so he he literally in his own
comparison is comparing trump's health
to barack obama who was here the most
active right of all of that right and
really honestly i'm [ __ ] barack
obama's no bigger than my goddamn arm
yeah like he's a scrawny little son of a
[ __ ] yeah but he's jealous of barack
obama but he can he can ball man even
after he stops smoking he didn't get fat
this is all right [ __ ] you know what
i mean exactly you know
for ronnie jackson to say that he's the
healthiest president ever even the
healthiest president he's ever seen we
know he's a [ __ ] idiot but here's the
thing ronnie jackson a couple weeks ago
we found out that during the
insurrection ronnie jackson was seeking
uh protection from
the oath keepers and the proud boys i
believe the oath keeper's impetus
keepers yep because he had some
some important data he needed to get to
the president or something critical
critical data yeah right so so i think
we're going to find out in this hearing
what that was and how much of a trader
ronnie jackson is the reason why i
believe that because of this tweet he
has lost his [ __ ] mind like dude
rocker this is what happens when
somebody has like three bottles deep of
whiskey
they're
they're beginning whiskey or tequila i
don't know i don't know it's bottom
shelf stuff i can take that
i would take ronnie as a tequila guy you
think so right maybe even
maybe even vodka
so you know you can't smell it maybe you
know that way
can you pretend to still be i mean he
might just drink straight ever clear
honestly like he might be just like you
know what's better than that it's ever
clear because it's whatever
it is
yeah because that's what his tweet
sounds like here let me read the tweet
here he says the witch hunt and truce
trump style and can all caps committee
of unselects which is another thing why
do they think that's a dig
i don't know i don't know i don't know
that's like the best they're like oh man
we got you so [ __ ] good dude
unselected licks like whatever i don't
know and he says the unselect is failing
again with the all caps here this is how
you know this guy's losing his [ __ ]
[ __ ] americans can see through their
lies it's not their lies it's every
they're just giving you what everyone's
saying
and here's the thing all of the people
that are talking are republicans right
what the [ __ ] are you talking about he
says and nobody believes them and he
puts nobody in camps which a lot of
people are believing this stuff yeah
because it's turning out to be
true
it's all a sham
cat all caps again meant to all caps
distract this is [ __ ] ridiculous like
did trump write this for him and send it
to him you think trump like text him
this hey tweet this please this is how
it went down i texted trump because he
texted trump texted me and said what do
i say right back to ronnie and i said
look look this is what you should say
okay and tell ronnie to say just like
like this right and then you get
verbatim no no edits we don't want seth
to get confused about what i mean i
really do love it when trump does
exactly what i tell him to do when it
comes to writing a statement statement
right so the very end of this is the
best part about it all
the committee should be dissolved
immediately well ronnie just wait a
couple months and it's going to be yeah
like what what are you talking about
like we're almost here at the end ronnie
like we are literally here at the end
i really do believe though this um all
joking aside this is ronnie jackson
knowing his name is going to be invoked
this week with the oath keepers and
proud boys right and they are going to
say [ __ ] that maybe we as the public
have not heard anyone say under oath yet
i believe i believe this uh data thing
um you know whatever the [ __ ] that is we
made we joked about it whenever it was
we joked about how was trump's real bmi
score right i think i think that might
maybe that's what it is i don't know but
some people are saying that it's
actually uh fake electors
well right because we've we've we've uh
ron johnson
has
and his staff were trying to get yeah
yeah it was something yeah they
because i'm doing a uh what was that for
tomorrow which is kind of a recap before
the hearings happen again
and what was that what was that what was
it what was that what was that i mean
here's the thing i will say this
there is
in each day i go through i'm like oh man
there's like at least four what was that
i'll save it for the last day which is
the cassidy hutchinson [ __ ]
but holy [ __ ] you get a full staffer
game so he can have an hour each day to
do what was that i think you could
probably do i mean it would be great if
i could do that but
this is one of those moments where you
look at the situation you're like ronnie
jackson was in was mentioned in oath
keepers texts and how he needed to get
cover
so when you're gonna have oath keepers
brought up and proud boys brought up on
tuesday maybe thursday as well
his name is 100 gonna be brought up
because these text messages are part of
the [ __ ] record and i bet it makes
him look like a [ __ ] traitor because
that's what he is yeah and that's why
he's freaking out you even said here in
your tweet and you're uh of this of the
screenshot and yes it is a real
screenshot yeah didn't make it i even
linked it below mine just so people
would know right just so people would
understand that it it is not against
democracy gabe is an actual
what it says uh gabe said this is not a
normal reaction innocent people do not
freak out like this ronnie jackson is
afraid that people will find out why the
oath keepers needed to cover him and
what the critical data those are quotes
from the text messages that we've seen
he was protecting on january 6. um
you know it's going to turn out that
this critical data that they needed to
cover him is a bunch of nonsense
[ __ ] it's all the data is probably
lies right right um whatever the data he
was carrying whether it's trump's weight
or his bmi or it's actually what you're
surmising which i think that is probably
what it was
was actually an envelope full of right
fake because they had not the thing that
people need to realize here is the
reason it's so important especially for
ron johns uh uh ron johnson is because
those things were not just
ronnie jackson because
no well ron johnson was the one who had
the fake electors for michigan and
wisconsin
and the reason it's so important is
because he did not uh the the the
electors were not submitted to the
archives yet so nothing was on record so
ron johnson was hoping to intercept this
switch out for the fake ones you know
like some sort of crazy
uh
like ocean's 11 type scenario like it's
all out of a movie or some shady back
alley drug deal i don't know which one
but either one that's what he was hoping
for obviously and thankfully
unsuccessful but like that's one of
those things where it's like i don't
know if ronnie jackson had other
electors in addition to ron johnson well
here may be some evidence to this
because christina bob that [ __ ]
trader she used to be she used to work
for department of homeland security she
was in the war rooms standing next to
rudy giuliani and steve banning as they
were trying to steal our government here
she is on rsbn in alaska at the nazi
rally surmising what their next step in
the coup is about the state electors
listen to this [ __ ] just absolute
bonkers ass delusional [ __ ] evidence
that joe biden inside cheated so they
could withdraw their electors or they
could actually decide to award trump
electors although i would anticipate
they would probably just withdraw the
electors so here's this elector talk
again and it's that same [ __ ] [ __ ]
that they're trying to push on america
that their second slate of electors
which is nonsense let's listen and if
that happens from three different states
three different resolutions go into
congress and i'm sorry i'm summarizing
this it's a complicated issue but i
would have to go into the u.s congress
to decide whether they want to accept
the resolutions whether they want to act
on them or not so the complex
issue that needs to be handled complexly
by different state legislatures and the
u.s congress these are things that do
not exist this is [ __ ] that does not
exist the state government or any
legislator does not have the ability to
go back and change the certification of
an election they do not have that
ability right that congress our congress
does not have the ability to go back and
change the results of an election they
do not retroactively they do not have
that discretion they do not have that
power that is not something that even
exists this is all nonsense this is all
[ __ ] that they're trying to sell to
their base and the reason why is because
i bet you're right tomorrow during the
hearing which the time has changed
everybody the time has changed it is now
at noon eastern is when we will start
our coverage here on the midas touch
network so go to the mind of such
youtube page and find that link for
tomorrow's coverage that will start at
noon eastern nine pacific for the
hearing tomorrow i think you're right i
think we're gonna hear a lot about how
the oath keepers were not only trying to
stoke violence but they were trying to
make sure that those fake electors were
being delivered right and the fake
electors are going to come into the
focus here of who is because they've
already mentioned them they've already
mentioned them previously and they
showed the screenshots and be like
here's the real one and here's this
shitty word doc version right right so
and ron johnson seems really scared when
he's walking around being asked
questions about these fake electors and
he's on his phone he's like i got a
phone call he's like you're not on the
phone really and and the other thing too
is that this christina bob as she's
talking at
on the nazi rally this weekend leading
into this week of the select the select
hearings
what she is saying is she's trying to
make the the electors legitimate
and remember this person was in the
[ __ ] goddamn
war room with steve bannon rudy giuliani
she she is even the
uh the actual architect
of the eastman memo she helped eastman
write the memo that memo that is now
now the plan for the cheeto dust
kangaroo so please join us tomorrow make
sure to to change your time in your
calendar of the january 6th select
hearing tomorrow our coverage will start
at noon eastern noon eastern nine
pacific
our coverage will start we will have the
midas touch network panel with you we
have the the legal af
crowd we will have uh the trump nda kill
or jessica denson we will have ron
reagan the the son of ronald reagan
president ronald reagan with us we will
have david bender um we will we will
also hopefully we'll have michael cohen
a mighty mighty favorite texas paul they
will all be joining us tomorrow in the
midas touch network panel tomorrow
during the hearing don't forget to go
set your reminder at noon eastern nine
pacific for tomorrow's hearing about the
proud boys and the oath keepers right
here on the midas touch network go to
the youtube page and follow us follow us
here on youtube d tony michael's podcast
where we broadcast every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific for two full hours
and we simulcast to the midas touch
facebook page until tomorrow when we
start this hearing oh my god is gonna be
big until tomorrow surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking